I'm Carla Cohen and one of the owners of
politics and prose and I want to welcome
all of you tonight and I particularly
were very honored to have Daniel Dennett
here this is I know that a lot of you
are here because of the importance of
the topic last week I went to see the
Darwin exhibit at the Museum of Natural
History in New York the exhibit was not
only a chance for a lay person to
understand more about Darwin's theory
but it was a glimpse of the culture wars
that we are now undergoing in the united
states throughout the exhibit one could
see purposeful answers to the attacks on
natural selection there was a discussion
of what a scientific theory is there was
a discussion of what the theory has
contributed to science and there was a
discussion of the difference between
religion and science and how scientists
can be religious for this reason it is
only and I used the word advisedly
natural that dr. Dennett would write a
book about the human need for
spirituality dr. Daniel Dennett is one
of the leading philosophers in the
United States he teaches at tufts
university and heads the center for
cognitive studies there he has been
consistent in his professional interests
looking at the question how can meaning
design and morality arise in a universe
that began as meaningless without form
he answers that Darwinism gives us the
perspective to see how meaning and
function and purpose can come to exist
in a world that is intrinsically
meaningless and he in this his new book
breaking the spell examines the natural
evolution of religion as a way of
explaining phenomenon material
phenomenon so it's a companion piece to
Darwin's dangerous idea and but a
completely different kind of book as
well so we're very very happy to have
dr. Daniel Dennett here
[Applause]
I hope it's I hope it's worth the wait
I'm sorry that I'm late getting set up
but you're very very kind to wait now
let's see if my technology will work yes
wonderful a few years ago I found myself
asking myself the question what's going
to happen to religion the next hundred
years or just in my lifetime what are we
going to see what's going to happen and
I came to the realization I didn't have
the foggiest idea what was going to
happen but then as far as I could tell
nobody else did either do a lot of
people that had convictions but there
didn't seem to be any way of sorting
them out just to give you an idea of how
sort of a strangely uncertain that is I
want to just walk through five possible
scenarios there's others but these are
just sort of five possible scenarios
what might happen to religion in the
next few decades in the next hundred
years something like this the first one
I want to look at is well the
enlightenment over you know religion is
kinda is going to sweep the planet now
which religion is it going to be it's
not really clear maybe it'll be Islam
maybe it'll be Christianity maybe it'll
be Buddhism who knows whatever religion
yours is if you have a religion it
probably won't be yours there are more
people who don't want your religion to
sweep the planet then who do no matter
what your religion is ah so worth
bearing that in mind well there's one
prospect here's another one is that
religion is in fact in its death throes
or some people who believe that who
think that what we're seeing now are the
last sort of chaotic spasms that that
within the life of our grandchildren
perhaps it will really pretty well
evaporate the the enlightenment
anticipation which was certainly what
people thought a few hundred years ago
they were just wrong but it's going to
come true just a few centuries late and
that who knows maybe the the Vatican
will become you know the European Museum
of Roman Catholicism maybe maybe Mecca
will become Disney's Magic King
the mavala do you think never going to
happen they were going to happen well
stranger things have happened after all
here's the Hagia Sophia in Istanbul
started off as a church of course then
it was a mosque now it's a museum and
that's in Turkey so who knows what the
future will bring there's another
hypothesis let's look at the third maybe
religions are going to transform
themselves into something unlike
anything we've seen on this planet sort
of Creed 'less moral teams with a lot of
teamwork a lot of pageantry different
songs different colors different
traditions loyalty you know would you
want your daughter to marry a Yankees
fan so maybe we'll have a sort of Creed
lyst moral teamwork with pageantry
that's that's that's a possibility and
of course there are some churches which
are already going in those directions
another possibility is that maybe
religion will just diminish and prestige
more or less the way smoking has you
know this is yeah you can be elected to
office if you smoke but you know you
should sort of do it you know in privacy
and you shouldn't interfere with anybody
else the practice of your religion maybe
maybe we can have a scene where where
religions are are tolerated of course
but but not encouraged and and certainly
not in any particular sense honored
there's another prospect rather unlikely
i'm sure then there's another one
judgement day arrives
and there may be people in this room
that's it finally he's got to the truth
you know that's what's going to happen
and and if you if you believe the recent
news week poll something like a majority
of our fellow citizens believe that this
is true something like a majority and i
don't twenty percent think it's going to
happen in your own lifetime well now
there's five scenarios and what's
puzzling about this what's what's
unsettling about this is following all
the one of these maybe all of them are
not just false but wildly false which
ones right nobody knows i don't know you
don't know nobody knows and it seems to
me that's a pretty shocking state of
affairs that we we are so unable to cast
our predictive eyes ahead and think
about what's going to happen religion
that's that was the state of mind i was
in when i decided it really is time to
see what's happening in the in the
attempt to study religion scientifically
the way we study economies and energy
budgets and global warming and El Nino
and freshwater and all the other
important prod problems a phenomena
natural phenomena in the planet we
really want to know what's going to
happen we ought to be able to get some
purchase on it in other words what we
need to do is we need to study religion
scientifically the same way we'd study
these other these other projects that's
all I'm asking but of course this is
frightening and disturbing prospect too
many people that's why this book is
unlike my earlier books it's not much
more in some sense political book it's
not it's not a philosophy book for
philosophers and it's not a scientific
book for scientists it's a book for
everybody about the need to study
religion scientifically the importance
of that and a sketch of how we might go
about doing it it doesn't have answers
it has questions religion is manifestly
among other things a natural phenomenon
it's a social phenomenon you can see it
you can measure it you can study it you
can do
istics on it you can look at its history
and that's what I'm proposing that we
should do something that is as familiar
as religion is something that we might
want to get a little distance from by
pretending we were Martians thinking
about what would Martian scientists
think of when they came to this planet
what would they what would strike them
what would what would strike them is in
need of explanation and here's one thing
I wonder if anybody knows what this is a
picture of looks it looks a little bit
like it might be a something you'd see
under a microscopic slide some sort of
interesting infestation there now at the
bottom I'll tell you what that is that's
a satellite photograph taken in two
thousand and one of the cool Mela
gathering in North as approximately a
million people in that picture gathering
on the banks of the Ganges and going in
into the river that's perhaps the
largest single gathering of human beings
it's ever happened on the planet happens
every dozen years here's a similar
gathering not quite so large impressive
but in a very impressive place and
here's another one certainly the Martian
biologists the Martian the XO Martian
fawn ologist this is what they call
themselves studying the animals on
another planet would find among the
phenomena that we're really fascinating
these tremendously energetic expensive
extravagant gatherings and they think
what on earth is going on here and how
did all this originated the answer that
is well it originated all fairly
recently by geological or biological
standards religion is very young it's
only been around for maybe tens of
thousands of years it's younger than
language and that's been around hard to
say some people think a million years
some people think a few hundred thousand
years agriculture is 10,000 years old
the oldest known organized religion
Judaism is only 2,000 years old or maybe
that's not the oldest maybe we can go
back
to some some earlier religions but there
there's no there's no well known well
understood religion that we can go back
more than about 3,000 years that's
that's very young and of course a lot of
the religions are much younger the
Mormons very recent religion and we know
that religions are born sects are born
every day the websites can't keep up
with them most of them last a few weeks
or a few months or maybe a year or two
and then go extinct we don't know how
many thousands how many tens of
thousands of religions have come and
gone in the last hundred thousand years
maybe it's millions gone without a trace
but some have survived and flourished
and leave a very big footprint on the
world and the question is why what is it
about them as natural phenomena that's
permitted them to have the staying power
the stamina the robustness the growth
these are questions that you can ask as
a historian as a theologian as a
psychologist as a archaeologist you can
also ask them as a biologist this is
these facts are perfectly visible to the
Natural Sciences is hard to know whether
the Natural Sciences can do anything to
study them I want to say in fact they
can these are these are good questions
that a biologists would scratch his or
her head about and see what they come up
with not just biologist but biologists
among others what's it for how does it
perpetuate itself second law of
thermodynamics tells us that nothing
complicated survives without renewal
without without repair what what
maintains these amazing structures over
centuries over vast distances of time
and space well here's another thing that
might really fascinate a biologist from
Mars or you suppose you were out in the
meadow and you see an ant it's climbing
up a blade of grass Cline's and climbs
if it falls it climbs again climbs and
climbs until it gets to the very
off of that blade of grass sort of like
Sisyphus rolling is rocking keeps
climbing up I think what is this and
doing what what benefit accrues to this
ant is it is it looking for food is it
looking for its cousins its brothers and
sisters is it looking for a mate this is
showing off what is it doing what
benefit accrues to the ant if you ask
yourself that question turns out you're
asking the wrong question no benefit
accrues to the ant at all well then what
is this colossal expenditure of energy
forward is it just a fluke yeah it's
just a fluke it's a brain flute the
lancet fluke it's a small parasite brain
worm if you like has climbed into the
ant's brain and lodged there and is now
driving it like an all-terrain vehicle
up a blade of grass because it the fluke
has to get into the belly of a sheep or
a cow to continue its life cycle salmon
fight to swim upstream so that they can
breed birds fly long distances we've all
recently learned about the Penguins what
an amazing thing they do die Chris
helium dendritic um has an easy route it
just climbs into an ant's brain and full
speed ahead up that blade of grass
that's pretty spooky it's not it's not
an isolated case there are in fact many
parasites that manipulate their hosts
here's another one tack the Toxoplasma
gondii I this one host is a is a say a
mouse and it has to get itself into the
belly of a cat well now what would you
do if you were inside a mouse and you
needed to get inside a cat what would
you do to that Mouse what you do is you
turn it into Mighty Mouse make it
fearless and bold so it runs right out
in the open it's not showing off its not
hunting for food it's not doing anything
to benefit
self it is on a fairly self-destructive
course but it's a great benefit to
toxoplasma gondii a-- now these are sort
of spooky cases where we have a sort of
hijacker that a parasite that infects
the brain of a host and induces suicidal
behavior behavior which has no benefit
at all to the to the genetic fitness of
the host and you might ask yourself the
question gosh does anything like that
happen in us a spooky well I'd like to
remind you that the Arabic word Islam
means submission it means surrender of
self-interest to the will of Allah but
it's not just Islam Christianity to this
is a bad photograph I apologize for the
quality of this of a piece of parchment
music manuscript that I got an ax paris
bookstall about fifty years ago and it
dates from the 16th century from about
fifteen forty and it's sort of
interesting if you if you squint just
right you maybe can read what it says it
says same NS twere boom de sot or autumn
creaseless the Estes understood
interesting little curiosity is that
xristos is spelled with the greek cairo
XP and then the scribe hasn't known that
the row was an arm so he's added an are
sort of a belt and suspenders so we have
chiro r is to us what's that mean it
means as anybody took first your Latin
will tell you the Word of God is a seed
in the sower of the seed is Christ and
it goes on to say on this qui out it
m-my name it in eternam all who hears
the word will have eternal life so
there's a quid pro quo now what are
these these are ideas to die for these
are ideas that inhabit people's brains
and inspire them to set aside their
genetic interest to set aside their
interest in grandchildren to set aside
the risk to their lives to devote their
lives to the furtherance of an idea that
has become lodged in their brain there's
many ideas to die for for instance
there's not just Islam and say
Catholicism there's communism think of
how many people in the last century gave
up their lives and killed a lot of other
people in order to further that idea or
democracy is another good idea that a
lot of people have given up their lives
for willingly eagerly justice freedom I
live in Massachusetts just to the north
of me New Hampshire the license plates
look like this live free or die that is
the motto of state of New Hampshire and
it's worth reflecting on the fact that
the moose may live in New Hampshire but
it doesn't have that perspective on life
at all it's it's there's only one
species on the planet that has evolved
the capacity to have an idea that's
worth dying for to have that perspective
on life I look around I see quite a few
folks that are my age or thereabouts--
or even older I'm sure a lot of you are
grandparents how many grandparents have
we got out there a lot how many of you
think that the most important thing in
life is having more grandparents
grandchildren having more grandchildren
than your neighbors not a single hand
goes up that's a stupendous biological
fact there is no other species on the
planet that does not have that as its
ultimate sumum bonum those want salmon
swimming upstream they can't think you
know I had really rather study French
literature you know
kids forget it hmm now we're the only
species that has found the sort of
conceptual leverage to see other
prospects of this sort this is an
amazing fact about it now people hear
this comparison of mine with the with
the brain fluke and I think this is and
this is ill-advised this is shocking
this is offensive to many religious
people you shouldn't use this and I say
no on the contrary first of all they
themselves make quite a big thing of the
fact that their religion that isn't like
buying a car this is something that they
are devoted to this is they are proud of
the fact that they have put their
interests in second place and the
interest of those ideas in first place
well that's the way it looks from the
normal human perspective and I'm just
showing you how it looks from the
biological perspective it's not that one
is right and one is wrong it says there
is this way of looking at the phenomena
of ideas to die for from a biological
perspective and it starts to make sense
of some of the things that we know about
religionists it gives us a different way
of looking at what makes us special as a
species and the role that religious
ideas play in that human culture is
itself one of the fruits on the tree of
life now the tree of life unites us all
now here's a picture of the tree of life
if I can get more anything to work now
you won't be able to see it from here
this is doesn't look like much like a
tree but that's because you're looking
from the top down right in the center
you can see the trunk and right in the
center of the trunk you can see sort of
a Mercedes sign there and right at the
right at the center of that is Luca
that's the last Universal common
ancestor that's an organism that is in
fact the great-great-great
great-great-great great-great-great
grandmother of us all not just the best
butt of every blade of grass and every
bacterium and every fish and every whale
that's the tree of life and the
scientist who drew this diagram had a
nice
sense of humor and put up in this corner
let me see if I can make it come on good
pushing the wrong button here we are
that circled their corner there's three
species lined up on the end of that twig
on the on the Eukarya branch and they
are coprinus homo and Zeya three close
relatives on the tree of life in our
genealogy you want to have these cousins
of yours close what are they well there
mushrooms us and corn well we're quite
different from the mushrooms and the
corn in many ways and I think the main
way we're different is that we've got
culture we have language we have music
we have art and so we have a whole other
realm of development which is simply not
available to these other species and the
fruits of the tree of life include not
only beaver dams which are partly
culturally transmitted you know the
Beavers sort of teach their young a
little bit it's not all just in the
genes there's there's some cultural
transmission and other species not just
the Beaver Dam but the but the Hoover
Dam they're both artifacts made by
mammals after all not just spider webs
but the internet the World Wide Web the
power grid these are networks made by a
biological species and maintained it
great expense and we can ask what
they're for and why they're maintained
and whether or not we're being perhaps
enslaved by something that we've made
not just a bird's nest but an ode to a
nightingale I find a lot of Darwin
skeptics Darwin haters who say well well
evolution just great for things like
birds and plants and animals and so
forth but but not for not for things
like like poems and I think
you think that a bird is not as
wonderful as a poem have you ever looked
closely at a bird and realized how
exquisite the design of that thing is if
evolution by natural selection can
account for all the exquisite design of
a bird I think you can probably do a
pretty good job on a poem too it's a
very different kind of artifact a
different kind of designer but their
fruits on the tree of life and even
human culture gets underway without any
insightful design designer to prime the
pump one of the things about for
instance human languages is they didn't
have creators most of the words that we
speak were never coined by anybody the
grammars weren't laid down by any
grammar king or lawgiver these things
are evolved products and they've evolved
not by genetic evolution but by cultural
evolution in other words there are a lot
of ideas cultural ideas items of culture
that hijack our brains that enter our
brains and then reproduce make more
copies we rehearse them over and over
and over again we think about them say
them again reflect on then we pass them
on to our neighbor some ideas do this
better than others they have offspring
that have offspring that have offspring
this gives us a different perspective on
human culture and on human religion
these replicating ideas include music
ritual art science they survive
translation into other languages now the
word for these coins here is a coin word
by richard dawkins 30 years ago in this
book The Selfish Gene he coined the word
memes for these now if you just have an
idea you know you just suddenly think of
a orange cat that's not a mean only if
it replicates only if you spread it and
it becomes important
and everybody starts thinking about that
orange cat then now we've got a meme on
your hands and what are they well he
says they're analogous to genes there
are Nalia s'more over to viruses what's
the virus so sort of make a gene doesn't
have its own reproductive machinery it
just happens to be designed so that when
it gets into a cell which does have copy
machine it takes over the copy machine
it makes more copies of itself my mind
slogan for this I came up with this a
few years ago is that a virus is a
string of nucleic acid with attitude it
just it provokes its own replication and
I've delighted to find the evolutionary
biologist who'd made exactly the same
coin that she was very happy she said oh
yeah that's us that's what I'm saying in
my textbook too so there's a case of
convergent evolution in the mima sphere
well now in my book as I say I have
questions not answers but in order to
motivate the questions I sketch sketch a
theory of how the particular means of
religion could have gotten started and
turned into the memes that we can
recognize today what's the evolutionary
the cultural evolutionary history of the
memes of religion and today I'm just
going to give you a sketch of that
sketch but I wanted to give you some
sense of the directions it's going
because there's a few surprising
perspective I think in it and it begins
with the genetic base you first of all
you this doesn't happen in chimpanzees
it doesn't happen in wolves or whales it
only happens in our species and efforts
to to jumpstart culture and other
species have not succeeded so there's
got to be some sort of genetic base than
which it starts and I want to suggest
part of that is something that in fact
we do share with dogs and cats and
packed with with many vertebrates and
basically all mammals and that is when
something surprising or startling or
puzzling happens our natural first
reaction is who's there who's there
we jump to the conclusion that there
might be an agent out there something
with beliefs and desires and this is a
useful thing to do because maybe it does
have beliefs and desires and it desires
you and so when perhaps some of you
experience this just a few days ago your
dog is sort of half asleep on the hearth
and some snow falls off the roof and
lands with a thud outside and the dog is
up growling who's there it's a very
useful instinct to have it we share it
with many animals but in other animals
it sort of stops there they they they
growl they look around they do an
orienting response so far but they can't
talk about it and they can't reflect on
it very much so it doesn't generate what
it does in US which is lots of sort of
phantom ideas of who those agents are
goblins ghosts ghouls imps fairies
goddesses angels who knows leprechauns
what happens is I'm and this is not just
my theory there's I discuss in my book
the literature that has developed this
in more detail we get in individual
brains and in communities of individual
bins we get a sort of population
explosion of invisible agents well which
are those survived the ones that are the
fittest as ideas which are those those
are the ones that are unforgettable
those are the ones that are so
interesting so vivid so peak went that
you can't stop thinking about them so
you rehearse them and rehearse them and
rehearse them in your head and you
spread them to your neighbor and pretty
soon the idea gets one of a talking tree
out there in the forest and it spreads
in it mutates a little bit and then it
has to compete with other ideas ideas of
rain gods and and bear gods and wolf
gods and who knows what other gods
mushroom gods for that matter and pretty
soon this population explosion is sort
it out on the basis of really
memorability so the first step then is
the hyper active agent
detection device that's what Justin
Barrett calls it what I call the
instinct to adopt the intentional stance
to treat things that you don't
understand as if they were agents and
this is what generates then a population
of phantoms of agent phantoms and this
competition for rehearsal sprays and
brains and some wind and some just go
extinct what are the winners for what
are they for what good are they
therefore living in brains that's what
they're for that's all therefore we have
to think about their own fitness first
maybe they're no use at all they're just
a byproduct of the way we're set up and
they happen because they can happen of
course once they're there they're
available to be pressed into all kinds
of interesting services so it's not
surprising that they don't just hang
around there as these sort of phantoms
for long what I want to suggest now
here's my riddle what do folk religions
have in common with squirrels rats
pigeons and barn swallows what do those
species all have income they're not
domesticated they're wild but they have
evolved to live in close harmony with
human beings many of their behavioral
features and other features their their
their their digestive capacities have
been beautifully optimized for living
off us they're not afraid to get close
but they know how to keep their distance
we don't own them we're not responsible
for them they're just with us and that's
the status of the original wild ideas
from which religions have descended what
happened was that the original folk
ideas of religion became domesticated
and in this regard this is like the
transition from spoken language to
written language spoken languages are
also wild means there's a lot of people
don't believe that there's there's usage
mavens and grammar scolds and people say
Tut you shouldn't say ain't and all that
who think they are protecting the purity
of the English language or the French
language is people who make it a point
of garb being guardians of the language
they're unnecessary that work does not
have to be done languages can do very
well on their own they have evolved for
thousands of years to live in us and
they're going to go right on living us
they don't need to be domesticated if
writing on the other hand that takes
guardians that takes stewardship you got
to teach people to write it's an
interesting difference and it's a
difference that we can also see in many
features of religions let's think about
sheep for a moment how clever of sheep
to acquire shepherds what a smart move
that was for sheep think of it what did
they do it permitted them they could
outsource all of their problems our
protection from predators finding of
food health maintenance all at a rather
modest cost of some loss of free me of
three mating was this a fitness boosting
move on the part of the sheep it sure
was I don't know how many been meaning
to look this up how many millions or
hundreds of millions maybe even billions
of sheep there are in the world today
their nearest wild relatives the
descendants of their common ancestor you
could carry off in a few arcs what a
fitness boost domestication was for
those wild ancestors of today's she but
of course it was not the sheep's
cleverness sheep are as you know not the
brightest of animals whose cleverness
was it well it was nobody's cleverness
except it was evolutions
earnest francis crick once jokingly
coined what he calls Oracle's second
rule is named after is calling Leslie
Orgel which is evolution is cleverer
than you are notice that's not the
hypothesis of intelligent design it
looks like it because what it
acknowledges is evolution blindly
discovers designs that are brilliant but
it doesn't without any cleverness of its
own without any insight without any
foresight just by brute force it
discovers these brilliant solutions and
the same thing happens in culture the
wild memes of religion got themselves
domesticated they acquired stewards
people who were prepared to devote their
lives their whole careers to protecting
and fostering and nurturing these wild
means that they have become domesticated
and that changes everything well again I
don't have time to do more than just
sketch a few of the uses to which these
domesticated God memes were put one of
the likely sources i get from wonderful
if sometimes irritatingly eccentric book
by julian james the origins of
consciousness in the breakdown of the
bicameral mind Julian and I became fast
friends before his death a few years ago
ok it's a wonderful book it's full of
great ideas and also some ideas that are
not so great just itself in sort of
evolutionary factor there's many people
that are just fountains of ideas some of
which are really good and some of which
are not so good and they're not very
good judges but they just let them all
fly and the good ones get replicated
other people do the editing Julian was
one of those and he pointed out that
when human societies got in a larger
groups he speculates that
decision-making became really
difficult for them it was oppressive
what do I do now what do I even think
about now this became a serious problem
as you all know there are a few feelings
more uncomfortable than indecision and
that's not knowing what to do next well
you can almost leap a claim and what
Jane's pointed out is there was a
population explosion of EXO psychic
decision tools back in those days ways
of flipping coins you could look at tea
leaves you could consult the entrails of
animals you could set fire to various
things and see where the smoke blew you
you could pour molten wax in the water
that were literally dozens may actually
hundreds of different techniques for
flipping coins it obviously served some
perceived or misperceived human need
people needed something to fix them with
some conviction and get them off the
dime and get them going on one course or
another and even if it was no better
than a coin flip at least it was a coin
flip that stuck I mean if you're going
to decide whether to marry the girl or
go to war you know flipping a coin is so
it's a little you might say flippant you
need something with a little more
excitement to it to hold your attention
so you have a ritual you have a very
important ritual maybe even a terrifying
ritual maybe even sacrifice a virgin to
get the answer then by golly when you
get your answer you do it so that's one
possible use for these god means another
one is as a prop in creating a placebo
effect this is an idea developed by
anthropologist named mclennan who
notices that all folk religions all over
the world there are shamanic healers
witch doctors and these have been around
for as long as anybody can tell forever
in not forever of course but as long as
we've been human groups and if you've
read Jared Diamond's wonderful book Guns
Germs and Steel you know how our
ancestors pretty well exhaust
sively searched the world for the
foodstuffs and the domestic a table
plants and animals in their environments
they also Jared doesn't make a big thing
of this but they also found all the
medicinal plants all the good
hallucinogens they pretty well
prospected whatever was there and the
techniques for delivering them for
cooking them for making them less toxic
and some of these of course are very
elaborate so we can expect that shaman's
everywhere at no small personal risk to
themselves have pretty well invented and
reinvented and reinvented the ways of
providing the disin all helped and
creating really strong placebo effects
through ritual basically we plannin
argues what these rituals are are are
this is folk hypnosis and folk at gnosis
really works hypnosis is a really good
analgesic it is a really it could it can
actually cure a lot of ailments now
think of this back in those days when
there was no regular medicine there was
just folk medicine just shamanic healing
if you were susceptible to hypnosis you
had an HMO and if you weren't you are
stuck you didn't have any health
insurance at all so there could have
been a very strong selection pressure
for susceptibility to hypnosis compare
this with now a case which is not
speculative at all now and that's
lactose tolerance in adulthood how many
of you cannot drink and digest fresh
milk a few most of you can those of us
that can that's weird for a mammal
that's absolutely weird for a mammal
post-weaning to be able to digest fresh
milk it requires a genetic change and
this has been very carefully studied and
it turns out that the people that by and
large can't digest fresh milk are the
people whose ancestry does not include
dairy hurting
those that include dairy hurting by and
large they evolved the ability to digest
milk in adulthood fresh milk the
suggestion and is there might be
similarly a coevolution between genes
and culture because after all dairy
hurting is culturally spread its it's
not in the genes it's in cultural
transmission but it puts a stamp in the
genes of those who have that culture and
we might have the same thing for
shamanic healing it's an interesting
idea there's some if you read a book by
a man named dean hamer a few years ago
called the god gene he thinks he's found
just such a gene that's which is which
is variable in human populations and
which seems to be ideally placed it's a
gene for a protein for a neuromodulator
a balancer and it would be just the sort
of gene that variation in which would
make some people more emotionally
aroused by various rituals are more
susceptible to ritual so this is not
proven but it's the sort of thing that
we should look for then of course
there's the idea of surrogate police big
brother is watching there's all sorts of
uses to which these various ideas can be
put and I'm not going to spend any more
time on this sketch of a sketch so what
I want to say just in summary is that
today's organized religions the ones
that have written texts and long
traditions and so forth are descended
from folk religions which were wild and
the religions that started off where as
I said like pigeons rats barn swallows
and so forth and when we became
conscious deliberate stewards of our
ideas this changed everything and it
changed everything in a way that I've
written quite a bit about in my earlier
books let me introduce a sort of
fanciful technical term of mind a
free-floating rationale what you see on
the screen here is a cuckoo chick
cuckoos you know are parasites they
don't lay their own they don't make
their own nests the mother cuckoo
when she's ready to lay her eggs she
goes to the egg of a host species and
unwitting hosts species she jumps down
into the nest while the parents are away
lays her egg with with the exit have
already been laid very often she'll kick
an egg or two out of the out of the nest
and just in case the host can countin
and then goes away never to return the
cuckoo is raised by the host parents and
the first thing the cuckoo chick does
when it comes out of it eggs and they
tend to mature quickly and hatch first I
wonder why is the next thing that they
do they actually have a depression in
their back that seems designed for this
they turn around they don't have their
their blind their their featherless
their the scrawniest satisfied you
little tease but they wrestle and wrench
and wrestle and wrench and they push an
egg or two out so that they get a bigger
share of the food that's gathered by the
host parents now that's pretty shocking
but don't worry the cuckoo doesn't know
anything about this the cuckoo is
blameless it doesn't have to understand
what it's doing any more than the lancet
fluke has to understand what it's doing
that they don't the rationale for what
it's doing is very clear but it's not
the Cuckoo's rational cuckoo doesn't
have to have it in its little bird brain
the rationale is not represented
anywhere it is simply uncovered by the
process of natural selection that's why
I call it a free-floating rationale and
those are the rationales of all the
bargains in nature until we bargainers
come along until we start representing
reasons and becoming stewards and then
those free-floating rationales get
augmented with rationales that we dream
up ourselves with our own ulterior
purposes so we have the rationale of die
cracy liam dendritic command of the
cuckoo chick and those are free-floating
that you know die Chris helium dendritic
um does a pretty amazing thing but it's
it's about as smart as a carrot I figure
you know it's not exactly a rocket
scientist doesn't have to be but when we
get to organized religion
we have stewards who think why am I
doing this they start being reflected in
thinking kuiba know who benefits who
benefits from this and of course often
the answer is going to be well it would
be a lot easier for me to do my work if
I had this feature that's the rational
thing to do we all try to streamline our
jobs make life as easy as we can and
even when we have full intense faith in
the project that we're engaged in that
very reason makes us want to do the job
better but but this also has a way of
muddying the waters and interfering no
longer just free-floating rationales we
begin to get these contaminated or
attitude with with human rationales that
are not free floating but are anchored
in disgust in individual minds so this
shift is a major shift from
free-floating rationales to represented
rationales it's like the rationales of
animal domestic aters if you look at
domesticated animals you realize that a
lot of their features are not for the
benefit of the animals there for the
benefit of the domestic aters so this is
a major transition in the evolution of
religious ideas or at least this is what
I'm suggesting here's a quote from a
theologian that I like if survival of
the fittest has any validity as a slogan
then the Bible seems a fair candidate
for the accolade of the fittest of texts
what this nicely draws our attention to
is the idea that in cultural evolution
it's the fitness of the cultural item
not the fitness of the people i would
guess that in the last two weeks i have
had the following discussion with a with
two dozen people runs like this oh you
think there's a there's an evolutionary
story to tell about religion I say yes
they owe what good though you think
religion does for us human beings what
what do you think it's for I said well
that's one question but that's not the
first question the first question you
want to ask is qu e buono whose benefit
what good does it do the religions maybe
these ideas have
evolved because they can because they're
just symbiotically living with us
because they can now I started off
talking about a parasite but parasites
are symbionts things that live with
others and symbionts are generally
classified into three kinds there's
parasites which are bad for your fitness
there's neutral lists which actually are
beneficial to you and then there's the
commensals which are neutral as you sit
here now as I stand here now each of us
is about a hundred trillion cells 100
trillion nine out of ten of those cells
are not human cells nine out of ten of
the cells inside your clothes are not
yours they're your symbian visitors
fortunately most of those are not
serious parasites they are mutualists or
commensals a lot of them of course you
couldn't live without without the floor
and your gut you couldn't digest your
food you couldn't live the same thing is
going to be true of cultural ideas some
of them are going to be so important to
us we can't live without them some of
them are going to be parasitic but not
nothing to worry about you know
athlete's foot come on it's not going to
kill you it's not Fitness enhancing but
it's not a big problem and some of them
are going to be just neutral and what we
should recognize is that these cultural
visitors these cultural symbionts are
what make us so different from all other
species it's what gives us the capacity
to have these perspectives on the world
and on the future that no other species
has now I think I'm you've already been
very patient I will run a few more
minutes if I may and I want to talk a
bit about a few of the interesting
adaptations of religious ideas I don't
think they were invented by any
individual
I think they have only free-floating
rationales but they're really potent and
they're beautifully designed and one of
my favorites and I told chapter on this
is belief and belief now what's that
well some people believe in God right
and then there's people that believe in
belief in God now some people who
believe in belief in God don't believe
in God they've lost their faith but they
regret that if you believe in believe in
God do you think believe in God is a
wonderful wonderful thing I gee I wish I
could believe in god I wish everybody
believed in God their distinct beliefs
right now here's an interesting question
answer more of one than the other and
the answer is there are more people who
believe in belief in God then there are
who believe in God well how do I know
well because essentially all people who
believe in God also will even believe in
God there's very few people who regret
the fact that they believe in God wish
it were otherwise so all of them believe
in God and they believe in believe it
then there's all the people who believe
in belief in god only then many more of
them than there are of the others how
many more we can't tell because here's
another feature of religions they've
made it now that they're now that
they're organized virtually impossible
for people to act on their belief in God
in ways that are distinguishable from
acting on their belief in belief in God
after what do you do if you just believe
in belief in God you say you believe in
God you pray you give money to the
church you do all those things because
you believe in belief in God there are a
great many people who seem to be
perfectly religious and in fact they
just believe in belief in God they wish
they believe in God but they don't and
you know what it doesn't matter and
their churches are quite happy to have
them the whole idea of belief in God is
on the verge of being replaced with the
idea
belief in belief in God which of course
puts arguments about atheism for
instance and have a completely different
light now just a few more items okay
there's Lucy and Desi and you know Lucy
thinks rock is to die for and Desi
thinks rock is to die for but Lucy's
thinking of Rock Hudson and does he
think of rock music the fact is they
don't really share anything do they just
a term they have completely different
conceptions of what this rock is it's so
wonderful now I submit that's so true in
the world of religion to say oh you
believe in God oh so do I I believe in
God but then if you examine the concepts
of God you see they're completely
distinct you don't believe in the same
God so what do you share you share a
belief in the belief in God and that's
pretty much all that's why the term is
so important well why do people cling to
this why do they why is it so important
that so many people cling to the belief
of just about everybody believing first
of all I have been studying the
statistics on this and I don't think
there's any really good and valuable
research that's been done yet on what
people actually believe for these
reasons something which I go into in the
book the brilliant adaptation of
fostering guilt for disbelief is playing
a tremendous role in our country now it
means for instance the politicians
absolutely will not admit it if they're
atheists because I know they can't be
elected here's a sign I took a picture
of this sign in rural Maine as I was
driving up to my farm good without god
becomes zero the idea that you can't be
moral if you're not religious is a theme
that is hammered on and hammered on and
hammered on by religion and
near as I can tell it has no basis in
fact whatever one of my favorite
chapters in the book is on the
relationship between morality and
religion and it looks even-handedly
looking at the evidence at whether or
not religion makes you moral no evidence
there's significant evidence that it
doesn't I like to quote Stephen Weimer
the physicist who says good people do
good things bad people do bad things but
to get a good person to do a bad thing
that takes religion and there certainly
are many cases of that there are also of
course in many cases of religion making
people much better than they otherwise
would be I'm prepared to look at the
evidence for all of that and see how it
adds up but we have to look at all of
the evidence we have to look at the
positive and the negative all right now
one last little bit that I'm going to
stop take some questions I have this
sentence up here on the screen which I
can't even pronounce its in Turkish but
I believe it well actually I believe
it's true fact does anybody in this room
we would like to bet me a thousand
dollars on the truth of this sentence
I'll take the bet I believe that this is
a true sense I haven't the faintest idea
what it means I believe it's true
because I asked a trusted Turkish
colleague to give me a true sense of
Turkish and not tell me what it means
that's what he did nothing mysterious
about this is easy enough to accomplish
this trick so here's a case where I
believe that what's up there that
formula is a truth and I have no idea
what it means so I don't believe yet I
just believe that whatever it says it's
true okay now here's another one e
equals MC squared you believe it hands
up all right how many of you really
understand what it means
yeah we got a few physicists here I'm
pretty good on it but I dare say a good
physicist could give me a multiple
choice test where I exhibited that I
didn't understand that all that well I
can do a few of the algebraic
manipulations but you know there's a lot
that's packed in there that I probably
wouldn't do very well and so here's an
interesting division of labor we like
people do the believing and we leave the
understanding to the experts and it
works very well in some areas there's no
reason not to do that even scientists
can they can do this they can use
formula in their own work but they don't
really understand but that's all right
because there's somebody in the next
department who really understands it it
works fine in most areas it works fine
in science it doesn't work so well in
religion so I believe both these
sentences but I don't understand the
first and I semi understand the second
but I'm confident that there are people
have really understand it in the case of
religious formula however even the
experts claim not to understand and that
is itself a really interesting
phenomenon you wonder how it arose and
why and I have some things to say about
that I'm going to end with the question
how many of you believe in ampule X
compressor hands up those of you who
believe in ampule X compressa you don't
know what it is and I didn't know what
it was until a few days ago either now I
know it is i believe in it you are not
equipped to either believe or disbelieve
in this oh it turns out to be one of
those parasites another one it's quite a
wonderful one I submit that the fact
that people are prepared to lay down
their lives if necessary in order to
defend their profession of belief in
propositions that they themselves
declare they don't understand is a
really fascinating fact about our
species just one of many now let's see
what do I
left here what I want to suggest that is
that religions are extraordinarily
interesting phenomena there are powerful
forces in people's lives and they are
brilliantly designed if you think about
them as brilliantly designed social
artifacts then you see them in a
different perspective you start looking
under the hood to see what makes them
work and very often we can figure it out
when we understand their design then we
can be in a better position to see what
we might want to do if we wanted to
revise their design if we wanted to
reform their design if we want to do
anything about religion whether we want
to foster it and protect it make it
better or whether we want to diminish it
we better understand how it works that's
the point in my book thank you very much
I thought your book was interesting and
that it seemed to be a book of sociology
written by a philosopher and it seems to
me you vastly underestimate the
influence of group activity sociology is
the study of groups and the sociability
of social interaction in DC if I wanted
to go to a church I could go to a
different church every day every once a
week and for ten years I wouldn't go the
same church if I wanted to go to a group
of atheists gathered together I think
there used to be an ethical culture
society in DC I don't even know if it
still exists but it seems to me much of
religion is prompted by that social
desire to be with other poem I got very
little to do with ideas oh I agree with
everything but the last claim and and
and you know David Sloan Wilson is a
evolutionary biologist who's looked very
closely at sociology and he's the sort
of chief defender of the sort of
sociality explanations of religion the
sort of group selection estoy dia and I
take David's work very seriously and I
think partly because he takes the
sociology very seriously and he's been
using as best
can and with a lot of informants in the
sociological community he's been using
their research to try to to confirm
hypotheses of his own I agree that I
don't spend a lot of time on sociology
in the book that's because I thought
people already doing a lot of work on
that I want to look at some of the
corners that are less less well
illuminated II the fact that you're
bringing some of the science to bear on
these issues I think is extremely
important especially at this time and
this idea that biology has something to
say about religion is something that's
long overdue coming from the the
academic quarter so I applaud the book
when you were putting up the the this
the list of ideas and you started out
with this notion of parasites and then
quickly went from cassava [ __ ] thalla
scizzum Islam to freedom and justice I
guess if you could have something to say
about the different role you see
yourself as a philosopher of science
versus a philosopher in general because
which seems to be missing is a taxonomy
of these ideas because on the one hand
these notions of these parasitic ideas
that religion and their their ability to
get people to do things against their
own self-interest due to the unlike the
values of the Enlightenment which there
are breaks on the extent to which we
would compromise our self-interest to
defend notions like freedom and justice
so if you could say something about the
different role you see is a philosopher
in this taxonomy of ideas versus the
biological approach to the overall
program thanks that's a very good
question i would say first of all that
the sorting of ideas into the parasites
the mutualists and the commensals is
hard in biology and it's even harder in
culture and after all you have to
remember that insofar as biology is
concerned what a what an idea is
measured by its effect on genetic
fitness but that just doesn't matter to
most of us lots of the ideas that we
very seriously religious and secular
like have nothing to do with improving
our genetic fitness they have to do with
improving our joy or our happiness or
our fame or and some of those may be
indirectly are traceable back to genetic
fitness but this is not about genes now
in the in the world of ideas in fact I
have argued in other works the structure
of ideas in our minds creates whole new
perspectives and whole new values which
people can adopt under certain
conditions and will and will spread and
then we can even get to the point where
we are evaluating them now really truly
normatively which which are the good
ideas not which are the ones that are
biologically successful not which are
the ones that are culturally successful
and we we know all these questions it's
not which song is at the top of the top
10 it's which is a good song and in
aren't always the good ones now once we
get into the land of normativity then of
course you might say philosophy kicks in
into overdrive I don't have a lot to say
about that but only a little bit in this
book cuz I wanted to keep the book short
I've had a lot to say about it in other
places um you we referenced um dean
hamer yes and i take it you don't agree
that he has found the god gene i don't
agree okay but you seem to imply that we
need more research oh sure [ __ ] I think
I think I think Dean Hamer's book is
interesting I think he's on to something
I think he has overstated the case by a
wide measure I think in a way that's
okay in a way it's unfortunate because
it tends to poison the well for people
coming after him who might make a more
moderate and subtle case but it's not
that he's got to be wrong it's just that
he's it's sort of that's a very / simple
account that he offers
how are you how do you see the mystic
particularly a pathetic mystic where
there's no image of God and also in the
kabbalists the aints of infinite
nothingness as a dynamic influence in
your design I don't have a lot to say
about that in the book but I have my I
have my own views on that I I do think
that part of that those traditions are
first of all this is something that's
not in the book but let me let me just
let me just say that I think that
meditation techniques are worth studying
in their own right quite independently
of any questions of religion and there
is simply no question that meditation
techniques create all sorts of
interesting phenomena whether they give
anybody any insight into anything other
than maybe the state of their own psyche
at the time is another matter and I am
actually very skeptical about that but
then given that that's the case that
people are motivated to build systems of
a sort of thought of a sort of the of
the kind that you're you're you're
giving expression to is it is a
phenomenon that I would count as sort of
its religion by courtesy but it's it's
it's not really religion I for me you
have to have a working definition and
for me my working definition is the
religion is a social system that
postulates supernatural agents whose
approval is to be sought in other words
a religion without a God that can act
and a God that can be prey to is not a
religion in my book it's there many
things which are like religions and in
the end that the definition is not that
important because I'm going to look both
sides of the line anyway you know there
was a time when we when people
classified you know dolphins is fish
turns out that's not a good
classification
maybe a lot of the things that we
classify as religions now we really
shouldn't but we don't yet have the
systemic theory which says what the
right taxonomy czar maybe just one more
question I think probably getting pila
is there another question no what's your
impression of gender differences in
approaches for religion it seems to me
that in most organized religions it's
the men who hold other leadership
positions and women sim card number men
in the pews and keeping the traditions
alive that is certainly the pattern that
is observable in many in many religions
of the women play very secondary roles
or even no role at all there are
exceptions to that I haven't done a
careful study of that but I think it's a
very good topic that deserves future
that deserves careful research in the
future I'd be very interested to see for
instance if there are any clear
parallels to some of the findings in
evolutionary biology looking at sort of
gender reversal roles in child rearing
and so forth that see whether there's
any interesting parallels are there
maybe but I don't know